donc mes chers collègues rebonjour et
comme vous le savez nous avons dû
reporter cette audition prévue le mardi
10 janvier dernier à 18h à la suite du
dysfonctionnement du vote électronique
dans l'hémicycle qui a obligé à
organiser un scrutin manuel dans les
salles voisines et je remercie vivement
Pierre Moscovici le premier président de
la Cour des comptes et ses collègues de
s'être rendu disponible aujourd'hui afin
d'éviter un report trop lointain de
cette audition importante
il s'agit en effet de nous présenter le
premier rapport de la Cour sur
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 dont la remise
était prévue en 2022 en application de
l'article 29 de la loi
2018-202 du 26 mars 2018 relative à
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 cet article soumet
au contrôle de leur compte et de leur
gestion par la Cour des comptes les
personnes qui concourent à
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques ayant leur siège en France
et qui bénéficie à ce titre s'agissant
des personnes morales de droit privé
d'un financement public mes chers
collègues ce rapport vous a été transmis
la semaine dernière en vue de cette
audition et je ne doute pas que sa
lecture va susciter de nombreuses
questions aussi je n'en poserai qu'une à
moins de 18 mois des JO des jeux pardon
le Kojo a lancé une partie importante de
ces marchés publics qui représente des
opportunités économiques majeures pour
les entreprises françaises
quel regard portez-vous sur les
modalités de passation de ces marchés au
regard des engagements pris dans sa
charte dans la Charte sociale et en
termes de respect des règles de la
commande publique donc monsieur le
Premier Président avant de vous donner
la parole pour un exposé liminaire je
vais présenter les personnes qui sont
auprès de vous monsieur nassermeda
président de la troisième chambre madame
Riou canals présidente de la section et
Monsieur Dominique Lefebvre rapporteur
général
monsieur merci madame la Présidente
que les vices présidents mesdames et
messieurs les députés très heureux de
vous retrouver cette fois pour de bons
pour la présentation de notre rapport au
Parlement sur l'organisation des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de Paris
2024 je veux d'abord puisque nous sommes
encore dans cette saison vous adressez
le meilleur vœu pour cette année 2023 et
vous assurer de mon attachement pour la
mission d'assistance au Parlement que la
Constitution a confié à la cour et
j'aurais à cœur cette année comme depuis
le début de mon mandat de veiller à
l'excellente qualité de nos relations et
à renforcer nos liens institutionnels
avec cette
je connais bien pour y avoir dans une
autre vie appartenu pendant plusieurs
mandats même si je sais pas si j'ai
pendant tous ces mandats 2023 s'ouvre
pour la Cour des comptes avec la
pulgation aussi importante originale de
ce rapport relatif la préparation des
Jeux de Paris 2024 et pour la présenter
j'en ai fait à mes côtés Nasser mesdam
président de la formation inter
juridiction qui a été créé pour mener
cette enquête d'ampleur et maintenant
président de la troisième chambre madame
Rio canal c'est Dominique Lefebvre
apporteur général un site monsieur
Lemercier qu'il va être quelque part qui
est là qui est des chevilles ouvrière du
rapport
au service extraordinaire avant de vous
détailler les conclusions les
enseignements de ce rapport je ferai
d'abord saluer le très gros travail
fourni par les rapporteurs je vais
également citer outre ce que je viens de
présenter les chambres régionales des
comptes notamment celle type de France
et de PACA qui ont participé à ce
travail commun avec les Cours des
comptes c'était nécessaire parce que
vous savez que là sont les sites de des
futurs jeux olympiques qui ne seront pas
qu'à Paris contrairement à leur nom je
suis donc très heureux de vous présenter
un travail inédit par son sujet d'abord
est-ce que c'est tout de même rare pour
un pays même le nôtre patrie de Pierre
de Coubertin d'accueillir des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques le rapport
est aussi original par sa forme parce
que la Cour des comptes a su et a pu
accompagner l'organisation des Jeux dans
une mission de suivi de contrôle continu
assez unique c'est une forme de contrôle
presque d'évaluation initinérée
comme on dit concomitante le rapport que
je vous présente aujourd'hui est un
rapport d'étape il doit être su comme
tel vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente cette mission exceptionnelle
nous voulons puisque par l'article 29 de
la olympique du 26 mars 2018 relative à
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 vous Parlement avait
donné à la cour mission mandat de
contribuer par ces constats
recommandations au bon déroulement des
jeux et à l'information des citoyens
vous nous avez demandé d'identifier
chemin faisant les défis qui restent
pour réussir l'organisation des Jeux
pour maîtriser les coûts cette
innovation répond au caractère
exceptionnel de cet événement pour
lequel l'exigence de transparence et
d'exemplarité est pas forte pour les
Français
compte tenu de cette mission compte tenu
de l'ampleur de ce sujet la Cour a
démarré ses travaux dès l'année 2019
elle a choisi de conduire une série de
rapports en temps réel et tout au long
des préparatifs de l'événement en fin de
vous présenter ce qui est en effet un
premier rapport d'état mais derrière ça
il y a une douzaine de contrôle qui ont
déjà été réalisés fruits des premiers
contrôles engagés donc en 2019 jusqu'en
2021 sur le comité d'organisation des
Jeux le kojob sur la société de
livraison des ouvrages olympiques la
solideo un premier référé
c'est une forme de lettre que le premier
président adresse au Premier ministre
sur la gouvernance financière et
budgétaire des jeux avait été adressé en
2021 au Premier ministre de l'époque
Jean Castex qui connaissait bien la
question pour avoir été auparavant
délégué aux Jeux Olympiques parieurs
membre de la Cour des comptes pour
l'exercice de sa mission de contrôle la
Cour a constitué ce que nous appelons
dans le jargon une formation inter
juridiction donc c'est plusieurs
chambres de la Cour des comptes et c'est
plusieurs chambres régionales des
comptes qui a conduit 10 enquêtes sur la
délégation est un mystérielle la dijob
donc sur le kojob sur la solide sur deux
thématiques fondamentales pour la
réussite des jeux je vais y revenir la
sécurité et les transports sur cinq
collectivités territoriales qui occupent
une place majeure dans la préparation
des Jeux
je tiens à préciser une chose pour vos
questions pour votre curiosité qui est
que la Cour ne contrôle pas le Comité
international olympique le CIO qui est
une organisation gouvernante
internationale non gouvernementale qui
n'a pas son siège en France et qui n'est
donc pas situé dans notre périmètre de
contrôle nous connaissons ces
engagements financiers mais contrôlons
pas au total la Cour a formulé à
l'occasion de ces différents contrôles
une centaine de recommandations et nous
constats nos alertes nous orientations
ont déjà été en grande partie pris en
compte par les différentes parties
prenantes parce que le fait de faire du
simultané change un peu le rapport nous
intervenons pas après nous sommes là
pendant nous sommes en dialogue constant
avec les différents acteurs je me
réjouis de ce mode de fonctionnement qui
correspond au rôle que la Cour des
comptes souhaite jouer que je souhaite
le voir jouer aussi pour accompagner la
décision publique au plus près de
actualités en quelque sorte mettre
davantage les mains dans le Kangui la
transparence est aussi un des leviers
essentiel pour raffermir le lien de
confiance vous le savez Messieurs les
députés qui est fragilisé entre nos
concitoyens et les décideurs publics
nous voulons y prendre toute notre part
comme vous le savez Jean dans le sujet
un siècle après ceux de 2024 les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et je parle
à pique n'existaient pas à l'époque de
2024 sont un événement majeur dans notre
histoire pour notre pays mais c'est
aussi un événement majeur pour les
finances publiques qui supportent une
partie certes minoritaire mais
significative du coût de cette
manifestation des moyens très importants
d'origine tant publique privée ont été
engagés pour cet événement qui aura je
l'espère parce que c'est l'ambition de
la candidature française des retombée
bien au-delà des jeux eux-mêmes il y a
une problématique qui est fondamentale
je vais revenir qui est celle de
l'héritage de la trace durable que les
seront ces jeux quelques chiffres pour
illustrer mon propos les jeux c'est pas
moins de 13 millions de spectateurs ce
seront 4 milliards de téléspectateurs
qui sont attendus c'est bien sûr la plus
grande manifestation mondiale d'abord
sur le plan sportif c'est comme si nous
organisions 55 championnats du monde en
même temps mais aussi sur le plan
événementiel et même
en politique géopolitique presque cette
compétition internationale est un défi
absolument colossal pour le pays haute
qui culmine pendant les épreuves mais
c'est en quelque sorte la partie émergée
de l'iceberg la préparation n'est pas
moins exigeante les décisive et les
conditions de la réussite sont
nombreuses et complexes la Cour a
cherché à apporter un éclairage aussi
exhaustif que stratégique sur en quelque
sorte les coulisses de vêtements
si ce rapport prescrit par la loi de
2018 est un point d'étape importante de
l'organisation des Jeux inépuise pas le
sujet la cour aura l'occasion
d'actualiser ces constats
recommandations elle procédera au
contrôle exposte des jeux comme l'a fait
par exemple pour les jeux divers de
Grenoble pour les jeunes d'Albertville
de 1992 donc nous reviendrons devant
vous mais plus tard deviendrons à l'été
je vais revenir et nous reviendront en
2005 25 et 2026 pour faire le vrai bilan
des jeux je préviens dans DJ ce qui
penserait qu'ils en ont terminé avec
nous aujourd'hui où elle était pour ce
rapport intermédiaire les instructions
conduites en 2022 sont intervenus dans
une période charnière de la préparation
des Jeux nous sommes en quelque sorte
entre la phase de planification
stratégique et celle de la mise en
oeuvre opérationnelle alors même que
tous les arbitrages sur les conditions
d'organisation et sur les modalités de
livraison des jeux
n'était pas rendu ce nous avons bien sûr
tenu compte je tiens à préciser que la
Cour ne disposait pas pour
l'établissement de ce premier rapport de
toute l'information qui est permis
d'apprécier la soutenabilité budgétaire
de des jeux c'est parti mon vrai pour le
kojob dont le budget pluriel a été
révisé le 12 décembre 2022 lors de ce
conseil administration qui fera l'objet
donc de notre part d'une évaluation
complémentaire au premier semestre 2023
comme je l'avais proposé au Président de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat nous
ne pouvions pas différer ce rapport nous
ne voulions pas non plus faire un
rapport incomplet et nous ne pouvions
pas entre le 12 décembre et le 1er
janvier faire un travail quelconque en
tout cas sérieux sur les chiffres qui
étaient donnés de mémoire
c'est sans doute la première fois que
nous avons cette tâche encore une fois
faire du chemin faisant et à partir d'un
périmètre clair et défini dépense de
champs d'organisation d'items de
commande publique je vais répondre aux
questions la course est attachée à
apprécier l'équilibre général de la
manifestation en pointer les principales
limites que je vais vous présenter sans
plus tarder je reviens en conclusion la
cour pointe plusieurs éléments
importants d'abord
nous sommes dans ce moment du passage de
la phase de planification stratégique
qui sait dans l'ensemble bien déroulé
auquel nous donnons sur une forme
satisfaite à la phase opérationnelle et
forcément c'est un moment délicat et la
phase opérationnelle c'est plus
compliqué ensuite sur l'aspect financier
si la majeure partie des surcoûts
constaté s'explique par des facteurs
économiques exogènes c'est l'inflation
c'est les difficultés
d'approvisionnement les jeux n'y
échappent pas plus que quiconque les
acteurs doivent rester mobilisés pour
que les dépenses soient maîtrisées
jusqu'au terme de la préparation des
Jeux d'autant plus que le kojob qui
vient tout de même d'augmenter son
budget de 10% ne dispose qu'une réserve
très limitée pour faire face aux
mauvaises surprises qui ne manque jamais
d'arriver
enfin la sécurité des transports sont
deux points de vigilance
particulièrement importants dans la
phase opérationnelle en matière de
gouvernance la Cour souligne que la
réussite des jeux repose sur une
parfaite articulation entre le kojob qui
organise la manifestation et les
pouvoirs publics
a été relativement consensuelle fluide
bien articuler au sein de conseil
d'administration qui regroupe l'ensemble
des partenaires pour autant nous pensons
qu'en phase opérationnelle doit être
encore resserré que le partage des
responsabilités entre l'organisateur la
seule idéo l'État les collectivités
n'est pas encore complètement stabilisée
ce qui laisse subsister des incertitudes
opérationnelles et des risques
financiers
l'accélération des opérations en 2022 et
2023 renforce le besoin de coordination
d'une part entre le coge et la seule
vidéo
d'autre part entre le kojob et les
pouvoirs publics ce qui veut dire que
nous appelons à ce que le rôle
l'autorité du délégué intamistériel aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques le 10
jujob
dont nous voulons saluer le travail
contenu du bilan favorable de son action
soit conforté
c'est à lui que revient au fond cette
tâche de resserrer le dispositif
concernant les ouvrages olympiques les
objectifs initiaux de limitation du
nombre de sites et l'utilisation pour
l'essentiel d'équipements existants on
prévalue c'est sage vous savez que seul
le village des athlètes
le village des médias
le centre aquatique olympique
l'Arena de la Porte de la Chapelle le
prisme qui sera dédié au sport
paralympique en Seine-Saint-Denis sont
des équipements nouveaux les sites et
ouvrages olympiques et paralympiques
devraient être terminé dans les délais
prévus mais ils sont prioritaires de
stabiliser les conditions dans
lesquelles solideo doit les livrer au
kojob et d'éviter de coûteuses
modification de programme qui pourrait
être notamment demandé par le CIO ou par
les fédérations internationales
une traduction très concrète qui est que
concernant la livraison des jeux sur les
sites olympiques la cour invite les
parties prenantes à accélérer le passage
à la phase opérationnelle pour éviter
des retards pénalisants il faut
notamment signer au plus vite maintenant
je vais t'exprimer dans un journal
sportif du matin vous lisez tous pour
dire
l'échec n'est pas permis on peut pas
attendre il faut signer au plus vite les
contrats de mise à disposition des sites
et les marchés de livraison pour les
sites on le COGEP en temps externalisé
la gestion qui ne sont pas tous conclus
ce décalage du calendrier qui est encore
pas choquant qui commence tout de même
entraîne un risque opérationnel un
risque financier avéré pour
l'organisation des Jeux cette situation
traduit cette passage délicat de chez
vous OK dans le passage à la phase de
déclinaison opérationnelle les enjeux
relatifs à la sécurité et au transport
restent des défis liés et majeur sur
lesquels la cour veut alerter en matière
de sécurité je dis alerté je ne dis pas
à l'armée
nous sommes très attachés sur les mots
ou les tortureront parfois en matière de
sécurité la Cour avait établi un premier
rapport en juin 2022 elle avait attiré
l'attention sur le risque capacité
majeur reposant sur les forces de
sécurité intérieure du fait de carence
probable je répète ce mot probable nous
pensons toujours que c'est probable de
la sécurité privée des prévisions ont
été faites elles sont trop optimistes et
ne seront pas complètement remplies nous
savons et ce qui ne sera pas fait par la
sécurité privée devrait être fait par
les forces de sécurité intérieure
en conséquence il faut que la
mobilisation de ces forces se fasse à la
hauteur des besoins et tout ceci soit
anticipé et planifié dans ce rapport
d'étape la course souligne que le plan
global de sécurité doit maintenant être
impérativement arrêter pour entrer dans
une phase d'organisation opérationnelle
des moyens si par site est sous
l'autorité des préfets par ailleurs le
risque capacitaire reste à relever
notamment au regard de la cérémonie
d'ouverture qui se déroulera sur la
scène
1 probable renfort pour partie de force
de sécurité intérieure pour exécuter des
missions qui relèvent de l'organisateur
doit être anticipée je le redis et son
financement doit être assuré par le
kojob autrement dit dès lors qu'il y a
pas assez de force de sécurité privée on
va utiliser des forces de sécurité
intérieure mais ce n'est pas au
contribuable de le payer c'est à
l'organisateur ça c'est un principe qui
doit être vraiment réaffirmé n'oublions
pas par ailleurs que nos forces de
sécurité font face à un défi d'équilibre
des missions il y a ce qui sera lié au
jeu qui va mobiliser donc prolon un peu
plus de monde mais il y a aussi la
permanence des mesures de sécurité sur
l'ensemble du territoire il s'agit pas
d'habiller Paul en déshabillant Jacques
l'enjeu de la cérémonie d'ouverture est
donc pratiquement central quant à la
bonne gestion des transports et des plus
de personnes là aussi ça a été abordé
dans un rapport en juillet 2022 ça
suppose évidemment une bonne
articulation avec les sécurités
or les risques de retard de livraison de
certains projets structurants renforcent
la tension sur le réseau existant la
cour mais particulièrement l'accent et
aussi mettre en garde sur l'impératif
d'achever à temps les infrastructures
nous pensons à ligne 14
ou franchissement urbain Pleyel aux
travaux de la Porte Maillot que beaucoup
connaissent ou chantier de la Gare du
Nord que beaucoup connaissent aussi
nous assistons aussi sur une
d'assurer la disponibilité des moyens
humains et matériels nécessaires au
transport des spectateurs des accrédits
c'est les sportifs c'est les médias
c'est l'éducation internationales c'est
les bénévoles il faut
rapidement stabiliser la déclinaison
opérationnelle de l'organisation
notamment en achevant les plans de
transport sites par site du point de vue
de l'éthique de la probité se rejoint
aussi une partie de votre question la
Cour indique que les contrôles qu'elle a
réalisé concernant la passation d'un
échantillon de marché c'était qu'un
échantillon nous irons plus loin par la
suite c'est pour ça que je mettais en
garde pour ceux qui penseraient qu'on en
a fini avec la cour non nous regardons
ensuite
marcher par marché de manière exhaustive
qui a été fait donc personne ne pense
qu'il y a l'inquiétude mais jusqu'à
présent non nous n'avons pas considérer
qu'il y avait des irrégularités
toutefois il faut garder en mémoire que
les risques liés à l'exigence de
livraison des sites et de la
manifestation sont importants dans la
phase qui commence la phase
opérationnelle d'autant que les deux
tiers des dépenses du COGEP sont engagés
en 2023 et 2024
les deux organismes ont mis en place des
procédures pour éviter tout risque
atteinte à la probabilité c'est très
bien mais il faut aussi s'assurer du
respect de ces procédures et de la
capacité des dispositifs de contrôle
interne à revérifier la mise en oeuvre
c'est en particulier le cas du kojob qui
est lié qui est soumis au code de la
commande publique qui applique des
dispositions dérogatoires sur une part
importante des marchés qu'il passe pour
lequel il n'est pas astreint on respecte
ces règles formelles
je parle devant des élus de la nation
souvent qui ont été élus locaux
qui savent que quand on est pressé par
le temps
c'est là où surviennent les risques
d'aller trop vite pour parler pour
l'immo il faudra l'éviter c'est
également le cas pour la seule vidéo
lorsque les exigences de livraison dans
les délais ils respectent les procédures
du code de commande publique pour être
difficilement être compatible nous lui
écrivons noir sur blanc il faut
anticiper là aussi c'est un des maîtres
mots notre rapport c'est difficulté et
ses risques je redis que la Cour en tout
hypothèse en assurera le contrôle à
l'issue des jeux enfin le kojob et la
seule vidéo porteront l'héritage ce mot
immatériel et matériel des jeux
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est le
durabilité c'est le renouvellement des
équipements sportifs notamment en
Seine-Saint-Denis mais c'est aussi le
développement de la pratique sportive
c'est aussi des mesures sociales qui
visent l'inclusion ce sont des
programmes économiques en faveur des
entreprises
de l'innovation de l'emploi ce sont des
mesures environnementales l'état vous le
savez à adopter ce qu'on appelle un
programme héritage de quel que soit 70
mesures dont le suivi un combat la Diop
que nous n'avons pas regardé de près à
ce stade que nous regarderons bien sûr
qui gagneraient en tout cas c'est notre
seul observation être mieux hiérarchisé
170 c'est beaucoup savoir ce qu'on fait
d'abord
tenez peut-être quelques axes
stratégiques lisibles les contrôles
réalisés en cours n'ont pas
véritablement approfondie ces sujets ça
fera l'objet d'un rapport de la Cour
après les jours au-delà de ces
principaux messages je veux aussi vous
présenter nos principales conclusions à
ce stade sur la soutenabilité budgétaire
des jeux
il est clair que les investissements se
sont avérés plus élevés que prévu non
pas en raison de dérive financières les
néons sont pas mais parce que les jeux
sont à catalyseur de projet parce que
c'est aussi l'occasion de réaliser des
investissements attendus depuis
longtemps par les territoires il
apparaît de plus que l'équilibre
financier du budget du kojob n'est pas
assuré de façon certaine enfin le coût
réel de la manifestation sportive ne
peut en l'état être complètement
déterminé je vais venir un peu sur ces
messages concernant la seule vidéo la
maquette financière établit en 2016 à
1,6 milliards d'euros prévoyait son
indexation
l'inflation devrait conduire un surcoût
de 300 6 millions d'euros c'est le
double de ce qui pouvait être estimé à
l'origine du fait de ce que nous avons
c'est à dire l'accélération constatée de
l'inflation en 2022 par ailleurs des
financements complémentaires pour les
investissements réalisés à l'occasion
des Jeux dans une logique d'héritage
c'est la vraie après 7
la Cour constate que les engagements
publics des co-financeurs de la maquette
financière la Solido sont tenus sous
réserve des tensions inflationnistes
mais cette évolution sont davantage
résultée d'un effet accélérateur sur les
investissements publics
concernant le COGEP à présent la Cour
avait formulé plusieurs recommandations
pour la révision du budget pluriannuel
lors du contrôle réalisé cet été elle
demandait que le soir retenu que des
ressources acquises au mois de l'être
s'agissant notamment des partenariats
avec des sponsors et que les risques
identifiés en particulier l'inflation
qui va impacter de façon certaine au
cours des jeux soient intégralement
prise en compte
le budget pluriel que je établi en 2018
à 3,8 milliards d'euros contrairement au
dossier de candidature porter en 2020
près de 4 milliards d'euros a été
substantiellement révisé c'est le
chiffre que nous avons lors du conseil
d'administration tenue le 12 décembre
dernier pour être porté à 4,3 milliards
d'euros ça fait tout de même une
augmentation de 17,7% depuis 2018
la cour préconisée de sanctuariser la
réserve pour aller à de 315 millions
d'euros elle constate que celle-ci était
réduite à 200 millions d'euros en
parallèle toutefois de l'inscription
d'une provision police d'inflation de 75
millions d'euros
nous tenons ainsi à rappeler que
l'évaluation des coûts liés à
l'organisation des jeux étaient
essentiel d'une part en raison de
l'objectif affiché dès la candidature
d'organiser des jeux sobre ce n'est pas
qu'un mot la mode au coût maîtriser pour
les finances publiques et d'autre part
en raison de l'exigence de transparence
qu'impose l'acceptabilité des jeux pour
la population
n'acceptabilité de jouer à population
c'est toujours c'est maintenant devenu
un sujet compliqué on a toujours été
très fier d'accueillir les jeux les pays
se précèdent pour cette manifestation et
c'est un très grand sujet de fierté pour
la population française mais
accessibilité n'est plus gagnée d'avance
maintenant on va regarder en effet une
nuisance qui peuvent naître
éventuellement l'organisation des Jeux
notamment dans les transports les
problèmes de sécurité on va s'intéresser
aux questions d'héritage et on va
regarder le coût et toutes ces variables
doivent bien sûr être prises en compte
si on veut que ça marche
les chiffres avancés par les
organisations des jeux et les
responsables publics de 6,9 milliards
d'euros en phase de candidatures de 8,8
milliards à ce jour ne peuvent pas être
pris en considération par la Cour
d'autant que le budget du kojob a été
établi en euros courant alors que celui
de la seule vidéo est en euros constant
en 2017 2016 pourquoi cela parce que les
coups que nous connaissons reposent sur
les estimations fragiles sur des
périmètres mal définis dépenses
publiques et privées ne comprennent pas
non plus certaines dépenses la sécurité
des transports les autres dépenses
d'investissement de fonctionnement des
collectivités locales s'agissant plus
précisément et donc nous reviendrons sur
tout ça ce sera l'objet de nos rapports
Jeux Olympiques
s'agissant plus précisément des
financements publics identifiés à ce
stade qui vous intéresse au premier chef
ceci concerne pour l'essentiel la
livraison des ouvrages olympiques il
s'élève à 2,2 milliards d'euros seul 171
millions étant attribués au kojob pour
l'organisation en tant que telle de la
manifestation au titre des Jeux
paralympiques au total les crédits
publics engagés pour le kojobios s'élève
à 2,4 milliards d'euros dont 1,3
milliards pour l'État 1 pour les
collectivités locales néanmoins
on peut anticiper que le coût public
sera Infiné sensiblement supérieur tu
pourrais être autour de 3 milliards
d'euros après prise en compte notamment
des dépenses fiscales des dépenses de
sécurité des dépenses sanitaires des
déportes de transport qui ne sont pas à
ce stade dans les budgets de la gauche
du Japon
c'est pas une critique c'est un constat
n'est pas en mesure d'établir le coût
réel des jeux son impact total sur les
finances publiques en absence de
recensement exhaustif et précis des
dépenses d'investissement et de
fonctionnement liés au jeu dont une
partie d'ailleurs ne sera connue
qu'après l'événement et donc je vous
renvoie au rapport expose pour une
véritable analyse du coup globale des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
nous ont donc l'occasion de nous revoir
nous revoir dès cet été pour un deuxième
rapport complémentaire et nous revoit
après les jeux pour faire le bilan
la Cour estime essentiellement que la
phase de planification stratégique des
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques c'est
globalement bien déroulé pour autant
elle relève des points de vigilance
qu'il a conduisent à formuler 15
recommandations alors que s'engage la
phase opérationnelle organisation des
jeux que à leur voiture les risques liés
à l'exigence de livraison des sites
olympiques et de la manifestation ne
peuvent que croître là encore c'est pas
une critique c'est du bon sens la cour
recommande d'abord de resserrer la
gouvernance et de clarifier les
responsabilités des partenaires sur les
plans opérationnels financiers par
ailleurs pour garantir l'éthique et le
droit de la commande publique où je le
répète nous n'avons pas relever
régularité notable nous alertons
toutefois spécifiquement sur les risques
croissants la projet est une des jeux et
l'impératif absolu de respect de
livraison ne doit pas conduire à des
manquements au code de la commande
publique sont des situations qui doivent
être
ensuite pour assurer la livraison des
ouvrages olympiques et paralycom bonheur
la bonne articulation entre le kojob et
la seule vidéo doit être renforcé sous
l'autorité du dijob qui joue un rôle
incontournable et indispensable je pense
particulièrement modifications de
programme au respect des calendriers et
des budgets ou encore modalités et
calendrier de livraison des sites pour
assurer la livraison opérationnelle des
jeux nous invitons par conséquent à
signer au plus tôt je le redis les
conventions d'utilisation des sites et
les marchés de livraison externalisés
indispensables au jeu à stabiliser le
plan de gestion site partie de tout
risque opérationnel
ou plutôt c'est maintenant dans le
trimestre qui vient sur le volet
sécurité et transport nous appelons à
une vigilance extrême nous soulignons la
nécessité de finaliser au premier
semestre 2023 le plan global de sécurité
des jeux pour stabiliser les besoins de
sécurité privée dont je le répète le
déficit de moyens est probable nous ne
payons pas de mots pour planifier en
conséquence l'emploi des forces de
sécurité intérieurs nous recommandons
aussi de finaliser les plans de
transport sites par site et d'engagés
lors des clients opérationnelles
notamment la gestion des flux et
l'information usagers enfin les
incertitudes qui subsistent sur l'équipe
finale du budget du kojob impose un
suivi très rigoureux pour s'assurer de
la mise en oeuvre notamment en dépense
de révision budgétaire arrêtée en
décembre d'autant que l'État apporte sa
garantie en cas de déficit final du
kojob comme la loi de finance pour 2022
là entériné la cour dernier point
insiste sur la nécessité d'établir le
coût le plus complet possible des jeux
et pour ça un préalable consolider
l'ensemble des dépenses d'investissement
et de fonctions voilà un programme
ambitieux
qu'il faudra tenir dans des délais
imparti et pour reprendre la célèbre
formule des jeux il faudra
collectivement porter nos efforts plus
vite plus haut plus fort et ensemble
voilà l'essentiel de nos messages ou
continuerons à être très actif le moment
venu nous dresserons le bilobjectif de
ces jeux nous évaluerons le coût total
pour savoir ce qu'ils vont vraiment
coûter au finances publiques et donc au
contribuable nous mesurons aussi leur
apport pour la population les
territoires en termes de renouvellement
urbain de retomber économique et
d'emplois et je vais personnellement
dans les mois les années qui viennent à
ce que l'institution dont j'assume la
présidence pour encore quelques temps
toute cette période au moins joue tout
son rôle de contrôle d'évaluation de
transparence en direction des citoyens
et vous êtes dans ce rôle d'information
des citoyens pour nous un partenaire
absolument incontournable j'ai été je
vous sens un patiente Madame le
Président je m'arrête et je suis à votre
disposition et toute l'équipe de
contrôle pour répondre à vos questions
ce rapport est peut-être si ma
présentation est longue c'est parce que
le rapport est aussi un rapport
important pour nous je crois aussi sur
mesure les retombées presque il a déjà
suscité pour nos concitoyens
monsieur le Premier Président je ne me
permettrai pas de de juger de la
longueur de votre intervention liminaire
qui était forte intéressante et je sais
qu'elle va susciter aussi un grand
nombre d'interventions de la part de mes
collègues et donc dans un premier temps
je vais donner la parole aux orateurs de
groupe pour 2 minutes nous allons
commencer par Renaissance avec Belkhir
Belhaddad merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Président mes chers
collègues je veux vous remercier
Monsieur le Premier Président on nous
notre groupe pour la qualité de ce
rapport qui était attendu
utile et qui permet d'avoir un éclairage
extrêmement précieux quand à
l'organisation de ces Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques Paris 2024 je dois
comprendre dans vos propos que très
rapidement la stratégie des
organisateurs et quelque part en phase
avec les objectifs et que la dimension
opérationnelle doit être un peu plus
maîtrisée et accéléré
faut noter quelques
quelques incertitudes et points de
vigilance comme les moyens de suivi les
montants des droits télé ou les
signatures de convention de mise à
disposition de sites qui peuvent avoir
notamment un impact financier important
j'ai plusieurs questions la première
concerne la maîtrise des risques liés
aux demandes de modification de
programme de la part du COJO provenant
soit du CIO ou des fédérations
internationales de même que seul lié au
transfert des ouvrages de la Cedeo vers
la Kojo vers le Kojo pardon au début de
l'année 2024 vous évoquez notamment de
la redimensionnement
des scénarios de remédier
redimensionnement pardon du Kojo est-ce
que ce point de ce point des demandes de
modification on fait partie ou pas et
selon vous qu'est-ce qui explique que
vous préconisations sur les scénarios
n'a pas été insuffisamment mis en oeuvre
j'ai une seconde question concernant le
budget notamment le conseil
d'administration du co- jours qui avait
prévu le 12 décembre
le dernier une augmentation de 143
millions d'euros de recettes sur la
billetterie est-ce que pour vous elle
est liée à des capacités supplémentaires
dans les enceintes ou une augmentation
des prix des billets enfin dernière
question concernant le Stade de France
l'indisponibilité de celui-ci j'aimerais
des pertes d'exploitation celles-ci
sont-elles supportées par le COJO ou
pour vous par le gestionnaire de
l'équipement merci pour vos réponses
merci monsieur le député pour le
rassemblement national angélique Franck
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la Cour des comptes chers
collègues le rapport fait acte d'un
avancement certain faisant confiance aux
équipes compétentes pour faire rayonner
la France à travers l'organisation des
compétitions et des festivités liées aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques en 2024
mon point portera son surprise davantage
sur la sécurité
en effet les risques sont là et ils sont
suivis par des défis notamment
capacitaires à relever le rapport et
lucide sur les difficultés que l'État
rencontre pour mettre en place les
dispositifs de sécurité primordiaux
cependant la dizaine de pages ou latence
et sujets ne sont pas moins alarmantes
que les informations perçues par les
Français et les élus ce sujet me paraît
absolument primordial pour nos
concitoyens s'il en espère une bonne
acceptabilité des jeux
le millefeuille de réflexion de comité
de groupes de travail doit s'accorder
sur une politique unilatérale afin de
laisser place à l'opérationnel des
décisions rapides doivent être prises et
actées pour qu'aucun drame ne survienne
que c'est les craintes populaires se
disent vous l'avez écrit des
responsabilités à clarifier une
programmation opérationnelle à décliner
et un défi capacitaire à relever
les Français sont fiers d'accueillir les
jeux mais ils ne sont pas prêts à
sacrifier leur sécurité ou le
bouleversement instable de leur
quotidien pour cette gouvernement de les
rassurer par un plan de sécurité de
gestion de flux concrets arrêtés et
suffisant de ce fait à 18 mois des Jeux
nous attendons en corrélation avec le
rapport de la Cour le plan de sécurité
globale finale comprenant la stratégie
adoptée pour recruter les plus de 30 000
agents de sécurité privée les 35000
agents des forces de sécurité intérieure
les 10 000 militaires quotidiens
nécessaires les 45 000 bénévoles
attendus mais aussi le personnel pour la
sécurité dans les aéroports
pensez-vous réellement que nous soyons
mesures des ficeler et de tester les
dispositifs de sécurité avant les JO
comme il était prévu pour la Coupe du
monde de rugby je vous remercie merci
madame la députée pour elle est finie
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président
présenté à 6,8 milliards en face de
candidature le budget des Jeux
Olympiques est paralympiques de Paris
2024 dépasse aujourd'hui les 8 milliards
d'euros et demain des incertitudes
substantielles subsistent sur les
recettes attendues soulignent votre
rapport des risques majeurs sont
identifiés en dépense complétez-vous la
réserve pour aller à est déjà consommé
pour plus d'un tiers et vous l'avez
rappelé la Cour des comptes pointe
l'artificiel sous-évaluation du coût des
Jeux Olympiques son estimation actuelle
ignorant les dépenses de sécurité et les
dépenses de transport à la charge de
l'État des collectivités locales et des
opérateurs
à vous lire donc nous pouvons nous
demander si le président de la
République n'est pas dans une forme de
déni lui qui déclarait en juillet
dernier n'avoir pas d'inquiétude
martelan qu'il n'y avait je cite pas de
dérive en matière de coût en 2021 à
Tokyo les Jeux Olympiques ont coûté deux
fois et demi plus cher que le budget
prévu initialement passez la fête c'est
l'État qui est passé à la caisse
certes la France n'est pas le Japon et
la covid en tout cas à cette heure ne
fait pas peser les mêmes incertitudes
sur l'organisation des compétitions mais
en France comme au Japon il y aura un
impôt Jo payé par le contribuable
par une hausse de la fiscalité ou par
une baisse des moyens de nos services
publics
alors que l'hôpital public est à
l'agonie que l'école publique fait face
à la pénurie pouvez-vous monsieur le
Premier Président nous dire combien de
lits dans nos hôpitaux combien de poste
d'enseignants la hausse du budget des JO
coûtera-t-elle au pays
merci monsieur le député pour les
républicains Maximino
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président si nous sommes de
faire vent défenseur de la réussite d'un
tel événement sur notre territoire il
nous faut faire preuve de lucidité de
prudence et de sagesse en effet la
nécessité d'anticiper une mobilisation
générale et massive des moyens matériels
et humains afin d'assurer la sécurité de
ces jeux est un impératif j'entends
d'ailleurs parfaitement vos inquiétudes
concernant la cérémonie qui aura lieu
sur la scène 200 bateaux et 600 000
spectateurs sont attendus vous suggérez
d'ailleurs d'en réduire la flotte
qu'entendez-vous par cette réduction
aviez-vous un chiffre en tête que vous
estimez raisonnable
car il nous certes il nous faut certes
effectivement penser à la sécurité mais
aussi aux capacités que demande un tel
nombre d'athlètes présents vous proposez
également de faire des simulations en
amont cela signifie bien évidemment un
déploiement colossal des forces de
l'ordre sur des périodes ou plusieurs
risques sont à gérer comme la menace
terroriste comment imaginez-vous ces
simulations et à quelle fréquence nous
parlons également régulièrement de
lorsque nous étions ces jeux du manque
cruel et nous avons été plusieurs à le
dire précédemment d'agents privés de
sécurité alors que le besoin un
journalier serait estimé à peu près 24
000 nous avons notamment déjà échangé
plusieurs fois avec plusieurs acteurs
sur ce sujet et nous savons qu'un
travail est en cours entre la préfecture
de police de Paris le ministère de
l'Intérieur et celui du travail nous
apportons bien évidemment une vigilance
importante sur ce sujet tout comme vous
mais nous évoquons en revanche que trop
rarement ce que là ça pourrait impliquer
sur le système de santé les pics de
chaleur mouvement de foule personne en
situation de handicap blessure des
athlètes nous pouvons réellement nous
nourrir au vu de la situation
catastrophique que subissent nos
soignants et nos établissements de santé
au quotidien de grandes inquiétudes
avez-vous quelques recommandations à
nous faire sur ce sujet et enfin vous
faites part dans ce rapport de vos
inquiétudes concernant le parcours du
relais de la flamme en proposant
d'ailleurs de réduire l'itinéraire car
plusieurs conseils départementaux
refusent de financer le passage
cependant vous le dites vous-même nous
faisons face à un risque de non
acceptabilité de ces jeux de la part
d'un certain nombre de Français alors en
faisant un tel parcours nous créerons un
esprit solidaire et donc primordial de
ne pas laisser les collectivités
territoriales sur le bord de la route
nous avons pleinement conscience que
cela a un coût mais leur ruissellement
sur l'ensemble du territoire est-ce
qu'il est ce qui fera pardon de ces jeux
une réussite et nous devons tout mettre
en place pour y parvenir je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député pour
les socialistes et apparentés Claudia
Rouault merci merci monsieur le
Président pour ce rapport sur
l'organisation des futurs jeux
olympiques et paralympiques 2024 et vous
recommandations le travail que vous
présentez est essentiel car les JO le
reportent unité leur cours font débat
auprès de nos citoyens qui ont des
exigences de transparence de sobriété
des tiques et développement durable
permet ainsi d'éclairer le débat public
sur les défis qui restent à relever pour
en réussir la parfaite organisation et
en maîtriser les coûts et pour être
aller sur les sites très dernièrement je
pense que ces enjeux sont partagés par
le comité d'organisation je soulève
toutefois une discrétion certaine de
votre apport sur un sujet qui est
pourtant crucial les conditions de
travail des salariés sur le chantier
alors même que plusieurs signalements
ont été faits sous la présence de
travailleurs sans-papiers sur le
chantier du village olympique nous
regrettons que vous n'ayez pas conduit
de contrôle sur cette question vos
travaux auraient permis de nous éclairer
sur la situation aurait été l'occasion
de faire des recommandations afin de
s'assurer que le droit du travail soit
bien respecté et les garanties des
salariés assurés cela étant dit je
tenais aussi à souligner que je
partageais à vous inquiétudes sur les
questions de sécurité vous mettez en
effet l'accent sur l'insuffisance voire
probable de la sécurité et le récent
exemple d'un match de la Ligue des
Champions n'appelle pas à l'optimisme
nous savons que les forces de CRS et de
gendarmes déjà sur mobilisés ne sont pas
extensibles à l'infini alors que nous
connaissons pas ce jour leur taux de
disponibilité des forces mobiles
pouvez-vous nous dire si des solutions
alternatives sont envisagées ou même
serait-il envisageable d'inciter le
comité d'organisation à revoir la
cérémonie d'ouverture qui enfin je pense
que ça sera le moment le plus
social au niveau sécurité et puis vous
l'avez dit il est devenu indispensable
d'inscrire les jeux dans les politiques
qui au-delà d'événements transformant
durablement les territoires dans
lesquels ils se tiennent et les
politiques publiques menées au service
des populations alors vous soulignez les
faiblesses du programme
héritage nous serons attentifs à votre
prochain rapport de contrôle sur les
politiques d'héritage au printemps de
merci madame la députée pour horizon et
apparentés Béatrice Bellamy
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président le groupe horizon se
réjouit de votre participation à cet
exercice qui permet d'évoquer un peu
différemment l'organisation des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques 2024 l'année
prochaine nous avons l'honneur
d'organiser cet événement mondial ce
sera non pas douter un moment marquant
de ce mandat et un événement phare de ce
début de siècle pour notre pays
leurs organisations relèvent du défi et
nous nous devons d'être à la hauteur de
nos engagements nous le devons
collectivement d'abord par l'engagement
sportif pour que les athlètes disposent
des meilleures conditions d'entraînement
et de compétition ensuite par les
engagements associatifs pour que
l'ensemble des bénévoles puissent être
associés à cette grande fête à travers
l'ensemble des départements et des
communes enfin par l'engagement
financier dont vous êtes le garant du
contrôle pour que la trajectoire
initiale ne dévie pas
en effet si l'engouement est certain les
incertitudes s'accumulent avec la
période inflationniste les tensions
énergétiques les crises géopolitiques
les sommes et moyens déployés laissent
perplexe bon nombre de nos concitoyens
c'est pourquoi en plus des exigences de
transparence de sobriété d'inscription
dans le développement durable que vous
décrivez nous ne devons pas oublier le
travail d'héritage avec mes collègues du
groupe horizon nous accordons une
importance particulière à l'après jeux
au lendemain de la réussite
comme vous l'expliquez la gestion poste
Jo est une des conditions de
l'acceptabilité de cet événement nous
avons pris acte de la création des
différents plans de gestion dit
héritage
aussi bien l'état que la Ville de Paris
le département de la Seine-Saint-Denis
mais aussi le comité d'organisation se
sont engagés
cependant vous semblez juger la démarche
du kojob pour le suivi et l'évaluation
des mesures pour l'instant encore peu
abouti monsieur le Président
pourriez-vous nous parler des tableaux
de bord dont disposera le kojob
permettant un suivi opérationnel de la
politique d'héritage ces outils sont-ils
déjà opérationnels ces tableaux
devraient permettre de connaître le
nombre
d'opérations de bénéficiaires il
permettront de mesurer le succès des
opérations les coût engendrer
pensez-vous que ces supports seront
suffisamment fiables et répondront aux
attentes de transmission
merci madame la députée pour les
écologistes du PS Jean-Claude Roy
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président Paris et ses Jeux
Olympiques et paralympique devront être
une fête pour les sportifs et sportifs
d'abord pour les spectateurs et
spectatrices ensuite et pour le pays
tout entier évidemment il y aura
toujours l'incertitude des résultats
sportifs et les performances qui la
rendront plus belle encore mais nous
devons de compter sur une organisation
irréprochable avec comme corollaire la
bonne tenue et l'acceptabilité d'un tel
événement et c'est bien sur cet aspect
que le rapport insiste la cour pointe
ainsi l'opacité du coup globale des jeux
et c'est extrêmement inquiétant surtout
pour les collectivités qui doivent faire
face aujourd'hui à de fortes contraintes
budgétaires cette incapacité à évaluer à
proprement parler l'impact sur leur
finance interroge
par ailleurs la Cour des comptes
préconise une maîtrise de la dépense
notamment sur le niveau de service mais
aussi sur les événements associés au jeu
tels que le relais de la flamme mon
collègue Mino l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
pour maîtriser sa dépense il semblerait
nécessaire un minima que le kojob fasse
toute la transparence sur ce que
recouvre le financement de cet événement
alors que 180000 euros étaient demandés
au département pour voir la flamme de
près les collectivités n'ont eu que très
peu d'éléments sur le budget
prévisionnel permettant de justifier le
montant prévu pour se passage symbolique
sur les territoires
chaque poste de dépenses mérite d'être
davantage précisé justifier autre
exemple sur la sécurité la répartition
du financement entre les pouvoirs
publics et l'organisateur n'a pas été à
ce jour précisément établi les
collectivités peuvent également avoir
des surcoûts liés à l'organisation
d'événements sur leur territoire comme
c'est déjà le cas sur d'autres grands
événements tels que le tour de France
des manières des manifestations qui
peuvent qui peuvent occasionner pardon
des dizaines de milliers d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires en s'ajoutant
en coupe prévu de la flamme
considérez-vous monsieur le Premier
Président qu'il existe un risque que les
dépenses des collectivités dérapent en
raison de son passage sur le territoire
merci monsieur le député pour GDR nups
Stéphane peu
le premier président bon nous avons avec
mon collègue Stéphane Mazar nous
conduisons une mission pour cette
commission sur
l'évaluation des retombées économiques
et social des JO on va faire un prêt
rapport en février un rapport plus
définitif en juin il y a beaucoup de
choses dans qui se recoupent et qui pour
nous viennent confirmer un certain
nombre de préoccupations notamment sur
les alertes
avec le temps la partie je limiterai à
deux questions peut-être que
j'aurais le droit à une troisième après
la première pourra être rapide c'est
dans votre rapport vous revenez sur le
choix du COJO de confier à des
prestataires l'organisation d'événements
olympique et la livraison d'aménagement
temporaire selon des dispositions qui
dérogent au code de la commande publique
alors il y avait un
avis du Conseil d'État qui sur lequel se
fondait
cette décision qui portait que sur les
marchés des tops partenaires ou des
partenaires dit domestiques mais cette
transposition au-delà de la lettre de la
vie du Conseil d'État
interroge
et je voulais vous poser la question sur
votre avis sur le sujet sur le risque
que cela comporte sur l'égalité de
traitement des candidats sur la
transparence des marchés soit la bonne
conduite aussi budgétaire de
des Jeux Olympiques d'avoir dérogé
au-delà de la vie du Conseil d'État aux
règles des marchés publics puis enfin je
vais pas vous demander un avis politique
sur la loi qui ouvre la concurrence des
transports notamment dans dans le réseau
de bus parisien mais puisque il y a une
alerte et notre mission la confirme sur
les transports pensez-vous
même pas la vie sur la loi qui ouvre la
concurrence mais pensez-vous que la date
du premier janvier 2025 pour ouvrir à la
concurrence les bus parisiens et avec
les risques que ça comporte sur les
transferts de personnels et sur la
difficulté à recruter et sur les
transferts d'un d'un groupe à l'autre
est-elle opportun ne doit-elle pas être
sans revenir sur la loi être décalé pour
la bonne tenue des Jeux Olympiques et
notamment pour surmonter les normes
défis des transports
merci monsieur le député et
exceptionnellement votre qualité de
rapporteur de la mission vous pourrez
peut-être poser une question ensuite si
vous le souhaitez
monsieur le Premier Président je vous
laisse la parole pour répondre à nos
collègues et puis après nous aurons à
nouveau une salve de questions
si
[Musique]
je peux vous question à la fois ma
grosse sur l'organisation des Jeux
attention aussi assez consensuel au
préoccupations de son exprimé le temps
des questions tout à fait régimes
auxquelles je ne prétendrai pas avoir
une réponse à toutes car je m'en
tiendrai à nos rapports notamment sur
des questions d'opportunités politiques
ça n'est pas dans le rôle que je remplis
aujourd'hui que j'allais dire quoi que
ce soit si vous le permettez peut-être
essayer de reprendre ou de regrouper les
questions par thème puisque finalement
se recoupent les unes et les autres il y
a toutes les questions de maîtrise la
dimension opérationnelle et les demandes
de modification vous faites par le kojob
par la vidéo nous avions en effet fait
une recommandation qui y est
des scénarios
redimensionnement ça n'a pas été tenu je
note par ailleurs qu'il n'y a pas à ce
stade de recensement et de consolidation
de l'ensemble des dépenses engagées en
dehors des partiels
du kojob 170 millions à la maquette
financière de la Cedeo pour les
différentes départements ministériels et
par les collectivités locales en matière
de Sécurité de Transport de sécurité
sanitaire notamment c'est pourquoi la
Cour a recommandé j'en profite pour le
redire ici une clarification de la
maquette financière à solide et pas
nature conventionnelle elle a aussi
recommandée l'identification dans le
budget de l'État comme dans une école
d'activités locales des dépenses
engagées pour l'occasion des Jeux ce qui
débouche sur la question du financement
qui a été évoquée par plusieurs d'entre
vous
sur ce thème là
je le redis en particulier monsieur
Vannier
nous n'avons pas constaté à ce stade de
dérive endogènes du coup des jeux il y a
des dérives qui sont largement exogènes
c'est l'inflation c'est une dépense
d'approvisionnement
évidemment l'organisation d'un tel
événement ne peut pas être tenu à
l'écart nous constatons aussi comme vous
que le budget prévu a augmenté passant
de 6,9 à 8,8 milliards d'euros nous
disons en troisième lieu que nous sommes
pas en état actuellement
d'établir ou même de préjugés tous les
députés d'un coup complet des genoux
l'établirons ensuite
faut-il en déduire qu'il y aura un
impôts Jeux Olympiques et faire ce
balance que vous établissez entre ce
surcoût éventuel est telle ou tel nombre
de lits ou de services publics
je dois faire deux observations
là-dessus d'abord c'est prématuré que de
le juger
le pire n'est pas sûr ce sont de la
dérive budgétaire
et troisièmement malgré tout pour le
coup je me tourne vers des choix
politiques qui ont été faits par
les ceux qui ont décidé de l'attribution
des Jeux mais aussi par ceux qui ont
posé cette candidature
il y a une préférence qui s'est exprimée
un choix en tout cas lorsque la France a
déposé sa candidature maintenant il faut
l'assumer il assumer aussi son coup donc
je pense que tout de même il faut partir
de l'idée m'exprimer par plusieurs vous
que c'est un choix de la nation et que
c'est une fierté pour les Français elle
aura un coup sans doute
pour le reste nous verrons ces sujets
j'allais dire
ultérieurement mais la cour à ce stade
n'a pas repéré de dérives et elle suit
attentivement mes évolutions du budget
elle note en particulier et je le redis
l'épuisement des marges de manœuvre elle
est très attentive comme plusieurs
d'entre vous l'ont dit à l'arrivée de
recettes supplémentaires et je pense à
deux choses je pense à la billetterie
je prends des tames sur le député de
dire quels sont les causes
d'augmentation de des recettes de
billetterie je pense aussi aux
sponsoring j'ai prévu là on attend des
grandes décisions ce sont des secrets de
polichinelle mais
ce n'est pas moi les trahirs ici je suis
pas positionné pour d'ailleurs je me
suis le représentant d'aucune marque
donc un sponsor
la marque que je défends c'est la Cour
des comptes
ça me suffit largement mon bonheur mais
bon ça ne permettra pas de financer tout
mais ça devrait en partie en partie
contribuer au financement des 10 sur
coups c'est pour ça que nous attendons
encore ces éléments pour pouvoir avancer
davantage j'ai été interrogé par ce sur
le Stade de France qui est un sujet en
soi elle nous a offert référer en 2018
nous avons constaté que le
concessionnaire n'avait pas été associé
aux engagements pris par l'État
vis-à-vis du CIO sur la mise à
disposition du stade pour les jeux nous
avons souligné la nécessité de faire
prendre en charge par l'organisateur les
pertes d'exploitation liées à la mise à
disposition du stade le programme de
modernisation du stade finalement retenu
qui ne pouvait pas pour des raisons de
calendrier d'Hélène notamment avec la
perspective de la Coupe du monde de
rugby à l'automne 2023 comme du coup
aller au-delà des investissements
nécessaires pour les jeux s'établir 45,7
millions d'euros l'enveloppe donc était
prévue initialement de 50 millions
d'euros et respectés en revanche
il y a eu un contrat de disposition du
stade pour le compte du monde de rugby
qui répond aux nationaux mais le contrat
d'utilisation du stade pour les jeux
elle n'est toujours pas signé à la date
de dépôt du rapport de la Cour en raison
de ce qu'on sait c'est à dire des
chèques de discussion sur le marché de
livraison des jeux qui conduit le kojob
à reprendre directement en charge la
gestion du stade pendant les jeux et il
faut que cette négociation s'achève mais
ça suppose que soit réglé les questions
que vous avez vous-même soulevé la
question d'indemnisation n'est pas
d'exploitation d'une part pendant la
période de mise à disposition exclusive
pour les jeux donc juin septembre 2024
mais d'autre part pendant la période qui
va de la fin de la Coupe du monde de
rugby jusqu'au jeu en tout état de cause
là ce que nous c'est que le Cool de mise
à disposition du stade sera nettement
supérieur à celui sur lequel c'était
engagé l'État en 2016 et nous avons
continué bien sûr à suivre cette
question une question qui vous occupe
surtout les bancs est légitimement c'est
la question de la sécurité et d'abord un
point
essentiel je veux dire qu'il à l'origine
de tout cliquez sur la sécurité privée
la cour alerté sur ce point dès le
printemps dernier elle a pris note des
dispositions mises en oeuvre tant par
l'État par le COGEP et pas la branche de
sécurité privée pour tenter de remédier
à ce que nous connaissons c'est-à-dire
des difficultés structurelles de cette
branche en France mais je le redis ici
nous estimons prudents de prévoir des
scénarios d'adaptation en cas de carence
partielle 4 carottes partielles que nous
continuons je le redis à considérer
comme probable et de ce point de vue là
il y a un autre précédent certains qui
est Tokyo qui le pressant des Jeux de
Londres qui oblige aussi préparé il y a
donc ce que nous avons dit c'est-à-dire
un vrai défi capacitaire pour l'État et
la cour à recommandé de faire monter en
charge les réserves opérationnels de la
police nationale de la gendarmerie mais
également d'anticiper les conditions et
modalités d'appel aux forces armées
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
établi en juin 2022 un rapport
d'observation sur les questions de
sécurité
compléter à l'automne par rapport sur la
sécurité de transport la gestion des
flux la sécurité dans les zones
aéroportuaires
nous notons que le plan global de
sécurité qui est préparé conjointement
par l'État et par le conjoint n'est pas
encore définitivement stabilisé qu'il
doit impérativement être arrêté pour
rentrer en face de planification
personnelle et l'organisation des moyens
donc nous allons dans ce sens-là nous
poussons dans cette direction ne tant
que le risque cyber est un risque qui
doit également être pris en compte et
que le défi capacitaire de la sécurité
privée comme la sécurité publique reste
à faire il y a une question de la
capacitaire quelle question financière
car je redis que dans ce jeu en quelque
sorte va se communiquant qui fait que le
déficit probable sur l'appel à la
sécurité privée va entraîner une
mobilisation supérieure des forces de
sécurité intérieure ne doit pas se
traduire par une augmentation du coup
pour le contribuable parce que monsieur
le député de revient dans le financement
il y a le coût global elle coupe pour le
contribuable et là si on est amené par
carence de la sécurité privée à appeler
des forces de sécurité intérieure alors
il faut que ce soit le kojob qui soit en
mesure de le prix en charge le coût
global de la sécurité de je ne peux pas
ce stade être clairement établi mais
nous savons que le budget a déjà été
substantiellement relevé il sera sans
doute encore donc il y a pas mal
d'incertitudes qui doivent être relevées
c'est la raison pour laquelle la cour
appelle à la stabilisation du plan de
sécurité
cite par site sous la responsabilité du
préfet et toutes ces questions doivent
évidemment être anticipé ce n'est pas un
point d'alarme je le redis c'est un
point d'alerte voilà on sait que des
choix ont été faits il faut maintenant
tirer toutes les conséquences car cette
question de sécurité sera centrale dans
l'axabilité des jeux que nous savons
encore une fois plus complexe ne vont
pas de raison de penser les contacts que
nous avons Mister à l'intérieur du
préfecture de police nous nous rendent
pas inquiets mais nous pensons que il
faut avancer sur ces sujets résumés
on peut étaler on peut introduire les
choses dans un tube encore une fois
c'est pas nous de dire si c'est mieux
une solution ou l'autre en revanche
l'une ou l'autre des solutions l'un ou
l'autre des scénarios ont des
conséquences en termes de mobilisation
des forces de sécurité et doivent être
inclus dans le plan de sécurité qui doit
être envisagée la manifestation la salle
d'ouverture par définition de dure 15
jours mais le nécessaire déploiement des
forces de sécurité intérieure en nombre
relève encore le défi capacitaire auquel
l'État comme le kojob sont confrontés en
matière de sécurité les choix qu'on fera
sur l'organisation précise de cette
manifestation parce que dire ce que
c'est sur la scène n'épuise pas le sujet
devront aussi être prises en compte donc
t'attendons pas trop en cette matière
comme on les autres je pense que il est
bon d'anticiper le parcours de la flamme
est une question à laquelle des députés
comme des sénateurs sont sensibles la
question elle m'a été posée devant
votre homologue de la commission du
Sénat
là-dessus je veux dire que la Cour n'est
pas compétente pour
apprécier
quel collectivités
doivent être retenues quelle est le sens
du parcours en revanche les chambres gel
des contes seront amenées avec Xavier ce
point dans le cadre de leur contrôle sur
les collectivités locales mais
évidemment je pense en effet que c'est
un point intéressant à suivre car comme
vous l'avez dit Monsieur le Député c'est
une question de réception
d'appropriation cette fois-ci pas
seulement d'acceptabilité de la
manifestation par les Français sur la
politique de l'héritage
là-dessus je lui dis je l'ai reconnu
nous n'avons pas à ce stade creuser la
question de l'héritage nous devons
simplement soulever ou souligner deux
choses la première c'est que c'est une
dimension essentielle toujours de cette
notion d'acceptabilité que la trace que
les seront les jeux doit être une belle
trace
économique sociale environnementale en
termes de progrès des territoires et en
particulier reconnaissons-le du
département la Seine-Saint-Denis qui est
en l'occurrence un territoire
fondamental dans l'organisation des Jeux
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que nous
souhaitons qu'il y ait une hiérarchie
donc nous avons un souci partagé avec
vous de pouvoir disposer de tableaux de
bord de suivi mesure par mesure à ce
stade nous avons peu d'éléments comme
vous hormis les 170 mesures du plan il
faudra approfondir tout cela et nous le
ferons dans nos rapports à venir enfin
dernière question que j'ai notée
l'extension la dérogation commande
publique la Cour rappelle que les
contrats passés par le comité
d'organisation
oblige le kojob avait au respect des
grands principes de libre accès à la
commande publique d'égalité de
traitement des candidats de transparence
et nous soulignons que le président a
été
responsables surtout les plans sans
exception
qu'on ne l'oublie pas
voilà les questions que je pouvais faire
aux différentes questions des députés en
espérant pas d'en avoir oublié trop
et on avait eu une je pense que vous
auquel vous n'avez pas complètement
répondu c'était la question de notre
collègue madame roux sur les contrôles
des travailleurs sans papiers voilà mais
voilà penses-tu plante sécurité tout à
fait mais c'est
le travail donc
la réponse était peut-être implicite
mais
mais c'est toujours mieux quand elle est
explicite c'est pour ça maintenant nous
allons passer à une deuxième salle de
question et nous allons commencer par
Stéphane Mazar
recommence parce que tu n'avais pas de
micro je recommence
et je vous remercie une nouvelle fois
madame la Présidente et je vous remercie
une nouvelle fois monsieur le Premier
Président pour votre présentation comme
cela a été dit tout à l'heure par notre
collègue Stéphane peu donc la commission
des affaires culturelles a décidé de
constituer une mission d'information sur
les retombées économiques et sociales
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
au-delà des bénéfices de long terme en
lien avec les chantiers olympique et les
aménagements urbains une partie
importante des retombées économiques
dépendra de la commande publique du Cozo
après examen de 18 marchés le rapport de
la Cour des comptes formule un certain
nombre d'observations sur l'application
du droit de la commande publique
le respect des seuils et ainsi qualifié
de points de vigilance pouvez-vous nous
en dire plus vous
identifiez également des faiblesses dans
l'estimation des besoins faites-vous
référence au montant et à une éventuelle
inadaptation des appels d'offres
enfin et il s'agit là d'une critique
plus sensible à mon sens vous estimez
contestable pour reprendre vos termes le
recours par le kosoft a des procédures
adaptées conditionnées à des respects de
seuil et de montant pouvez-vous sur ces
points également nous préciser ce
constat c'est le premier président merci
monsieur le député Alexandre Loubet
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président de la Cour des comptes
je salue votre rapport sur le budget des
Jeux olympiques de 2024 qui révèle de
graves impasses d'abord et vous avez été
assez clair sur l'urgence à fixer un
budget en matière de sécurité ensuite le
budget global des Jeux Olympiques a été
réévalué de 10% en décembre dernier vous
en avez parlé en partie à cause de
l'inflation mais aussi selon la ministre
à cause de cahiers des charges
sous-estimé savez-vous combien cette
hausse coûtera concrètement au
contribuable même si beaucoup de fonds
sont évidemment proviennent évidemment
de fonds privés et pensez-vous que de
nouveaux dérapages budgétaires sont à
anticiper notamment au regard des enjeux
sécuritaires et enfin la Cour des
comptes ne peut-elle pas recommander au
gouvernement de répartir davantage les
rendements des Jeux Olympiques sur le
territoire national de même bien
évidemment qu'au comité des Jeux
Olympiques afin que ces rendements ne
bénéficient pas essentiellement à
l'Île-de-France mais plutôt davantage
aux installations et club sportifs dans
nos régions je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député Cécile Rilhac
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président merci pour vos propos
liminaires et déjà vos premières
réponses très éclairantes je
souhaiterais aborder la question de
l'accès des TPE PME à la commande
publique solideo et ses contractants se
sont engagés à dépenser 25 % de leur
volume financier ou PME TPE au local un
engagement en passe d'être tenu que je
souhaite d'ailleurs ici souligner les
règles de la commande publique ont
successivement été modifiées notamment
par la loi ASAP de décembre 2020 et la
loi d'août 2021 portant sur la lutte
contre le dérèglement automatique mais
si son modifications semble avoir permis
une meilleure visibilité des offres de
marchés publics ainsi qu'une meilleure
prise en compte de la dimension locale
beaucoup de nos entreprises connaissent
encore aujourd'hui des difficultés pour
accéder à ces marchés au vu de
l'expérience apportée par la préparation
des Jeux de Paris pouvez-vous nous
indiquer si des pistes de travail ont
été soulevées par la Cour des comptes
afin de faciliter l'accès des tpeme
local à la commande publique sans
toutefois remettre en cause les
principaux européens interdisant la
préférence locale ou nationale je vous
merci madame la députée Léo Walter
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président votre rapport
d'octobre 2020 sur les polices
municipales indiquées page 70 qu'aucune
corrélation globale n'a été relevée
entre l'existence de dispositif de
vidéoprotection et le niveau de la
délinquance sous les taux de lucidation
manière polie de constater
l'inéfficacité de la vidéo surveillance
c'est pourquoi j'attire votre attention
sur un passage du rapport que vous nous
présentez aujourd'hui qui indique à
l'inverse au détour d'une phrase page 74
qu'un meilleur déploiement de la
vidéoprotection est indispensable ainsi
que le développement de systèmes
d'intelligence artificielle associée or
le projet de loi gouvernementale prévoit
à titre expérimental de permettre le
traitement automatisé des images de
vidéosurveillance et des camarades
installés sur les drones cela dès
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi est
jusqu'au 30 juin 2025 pourrait également
s'appliquer à d'autres manifestations
sportives récréatives ou culturelles
pendant deux ans au moins donc la vidéo
surveillance automatisée sera mise en
place en France pour toutes sortes de
manifestations il s'agit d'un
basculement majeur de politique de
sécurité qui mériteraient d'être discuté
ailleurs que dans le cadre d'une loi
portant sur les JO 2024 ma question est
donc la suivante ce changement de
diagnostic s'applique sur une évaluation
de l'efficacité et du coût d'un tel
déploie en les comparant à ceux des
alternatives possibles et si oui nous
souhaitons en avoir connaissance je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député
Emmanuel Antoine
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Premier Président le kojob doit recruter
en 2023 et 2024 pas moins de 3500
collaborateurs et 45000 volontaires vous
soulignez à juste titre que et je vous
cite dans un contexte de tension sur le
marché du travail et d'inflation sur les
salaires la réalisation de ce très
important programme de recrutement de
salariés devant intervenir pour
l'essentiel sur le fondement de contrat
de travail de courte durée est un défi
majeur pour la direction des ressources
humaines il est donc vital que le
cochoppe prévoit les conditions
d'accompagnement de ses collaborateurs
dans la perspective de sa dissolution
alors face à la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
que nous observons partout sur notre
territoire ces objectifs de recrutement
sont-ils tenables selon vous
merci madame la députée grâce à Léa
gradiquez-la Melchior
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur président les Jeux olympiques
et paralympiques s'ils ne dure qu'un
temps contribue pourtant à la
transformation et en rayonnement des
territoires il doit être une opportunité
pour repenser la place du sport dans la
société la pratique sportive par son
pouvoir fédérateur et inclusif est une
véritable source d'inspiration pour
renforcer les solidarités humaines
développer de nouvelles formes
d'éducation et de transmission et créer
de la richesse économique autour de
valeurs collectivement partagées les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
participent pleinement à cet élan
vecteur de partage et d'innovation ils
sont aussi synonymes de durabilité dans
le temps dans son rapport la Cour des
comptes évoque ainsi la question de
l'après Jeux Olympiques notamment autour
du défi de la fidélisation des salariés
employés pour la période des jeux une
perspective de plus long terme est donc
prise en compte dans les arbitrages afin
que les jeux soient un souffle pour les
territoires sur un plan économique
social et culturel
selon vous monsieur le Premier Président
comment la politique de l'héritage des
Jeux Olympiques est paralympiques
peut-être dès à présent peut-être dès à
présent mieux préparé et mieux
accompagner je vous remercie merci
madame la députée Julien audoul
merci Madame le présidente monsieur le
Premier Président peut-on parler des
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 ou des
jeux élitistes de Paris 2024 en effet
les tarifs des billets qui nous ont été
présentés frise l'indécence pour le
badminton jusqu'à 240 euros pour la
gymnastique artistique une belle place
coûterait 260 euros pour la natation les
sessions de qualifications se meneront
jusqu'à 230 euros dès lors comment
continuer à soutenir que les JO 2024
seront populaires afin de garantir
l'acceptabilité et l'accessibilité des
jeux au plus grand nombre la cour
compte-t-elle mettre en garde le comité
d'organisation contre l'augmentation des
billets qui explorer les Français les
plus modestes
merci monsieur le député
Alexis Corbière
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Premier Président je reviens
sur un sujet qui a été abordé tout à
l'heure pour aller vite je commets lu du
de la Seine-Saint-Denis et du 93 comme
on dit couramment j'avais déjà posé la
question à Monsieur cadeau le délégué
interministériel il y a un an et à
madame la ministre c'est la question de
l'héritage monsieur le Président de la
République se dit sensible à cette
héritage tout le monde veut des jeux
utiles responsables qui profitaient en
pleinement à notre département la
Seine-Saint-Denis mais derrière se
qualificatif d'héritage combien
d'emplois pérennes sont concernés
combien sont qualifiants quel bidon de
la clause de 25% des marchés devront
être accessible au TPE PME en
particulier du département cette
question implique des indicateurs précis
et précisant le rapport que vous nous
indiquez dit on en a déjà évoqué mais
j'aimerais qu'on y revienne que le kojob
devrait mettre au point des outils de
mesure de l'héritage fin de la citation
tout en précisant que les modalités de
capitalisation et de transmission des
expériences doivent également être
précisé alors monsieur le Premier
Président vous avez dit tout à l'heure
nous n'avons pas ce stade creusé la
question je vous cite il faut laisser
une belle trace économique mais avouer
qu'il faut aller sans doute plus loin
j'aimerais avoir à nouveau votre regard
là dessus sachant qu'on population de
Sandy de Seine-Saint-Denis beaucoup de
choses ont été promises et que plus les
champs s'approchent puis lancer
s'aperçoit que à ce stade aucun critère
n'est là pour évaluer que ce département
bénéficiera de l'accueil des jeux merci
merci monsieur le député Frédéric
meunier
oui merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président
transparence maîtrise des dépenses
exemplarité clarté et maintenant
sécurité c'est vrai que c'était aussi
notre demande nous en tant que député la
seule idéoconstruit des sites avec 64
infrastructures pour être livré fin 2023
à ce stade 96% du gros œuvre est
finalisé le cochon va alors prendre les
bâtiments pour les aménager vous avez
une réserve sur le coût financier de
cette aménagement je le comprends et
vous la troisième étape c'est l'héritage
pour une reconversion et c'est vrai que
là on est un peu dans le flou même si la
visite que nous avons fait la semaine
dernière sur le site olympique nous a
permis de réaliser que quand même tous
ces milliards qui étaient mis sur la
table à les bénéficier directement à ce
département c'est une belle réalisation
et ça fait plaisir de voir que ce
département sera les premiers Béné ma
question est simple vous nous avez parlé
tout au long de votre présentation de
recommandations quelle est la force de
ces recommandations voilà c'est quel est
votre voilà votre impact sur à travers
vos recommandations merci merci madame
la députée Béatrice Spiron merci madame
la présidente monsieur le Président je
m'associe au remerciements que vous ont
été adressés pour la qualité et
l'intérêt de votre apport et je
souhaiterais attirer plus
particulièrement votre mention sur les
mesures liées à l'héritage des jeux dont
votre rapport indique qu'elles
apparaissent en première analyse à se
disparaître le niveau est d'enjeux très
variable en effet dans mon département
des Yvelines je constate que sur les
trois sites olympiques retenus seul
celui de la colline d'Élancourt consacré
notamment au VTT restera dans l'héritage
et jeu sera donc utilisable par chacun
après les JO le site de Versailles
contiguë à ma circonscription sera quant
à lui totalement démontée après les Jeux
cela peut se comprendre puisque il
s'agit du parc du château de Versailles
mais cela concernait un moins trois
tribunes de 1500 spectateurs ainsi
qu'une piscine olympique ces équipements
qui seront démontés après le Giro les
géo Jo seront-ils démontables et vendus
pour être réutilisés ailleurs en France
lors d'autres types d'événements ou
installer là où ils pourraient servir
régulièrement ou bien est-il prévu de
les détruire quand toute tenue de
l'inflation du coût des matières
premières ainsi que de la notre volonté
d'avoir des JO éco-responsables et ont
assuré que tout a été prévu pour un coût
maximum de réutilisation un minimum de
usage unique merci merci madame la
députée
Stéphane peut
oui merci madame la Présidente je
voulais avoir une troisième question qui
est pas directement liée à
l'organisation des Jeux mais comme dans
votre rapport il y a une annexe sur le
Stade de France et où vous mettez en
avant notamment et on le comprend bien
là la mauvaise conjonction des dates
entre guillemets entre le renouvellement
de la concession
ou la session vous la gardez comme une
hypothèse et l'organisation des Jeux
sur le rôle respectif des fédérations
françaises de football aide rugby qui
sont dans l'actualité pour d'autres
raisons depuis quelques semaines mais
peut-être que le dénouement de cette
actualité annexe va nous aider à
redonner un peu de sens
de délégation de service public elle
s'est fédérations je voudrais savoir un
peu quel est avoir quelques éclairages
sur cette encart dans le rapport et
savoir si vous avez à ce stade était
entendu
préconisations
qui vise à
et qui souligne et pour avoir été un peu
témoin en 95 de la façon dont le traité
de concession a été négocié sous l'épée
de Damoclès des délais d'organisation de
la Coupe du Monde 98 on sait que les
épées de Damoclès en termes de délais
sont jamais très bonnes pour les
bonnes négociations voilà donc est-ce
que vous avez vous pouvez nous en dire
plus et peut-être avez-vous eu des déjà
des réponses ça nous intéresse
merci monsieur le député je crois que
tous ceux qui souhaitaient pouvoir
vouloir poser une question on peut la
poser donc monsieur Balard
merci Madame juste sur le fil merci
comme on avait déjà une question mon
collègue Loubet j'attendais la prochaine
salle de question monsieur le
vice-présor en fait je voudrais rebondir
sur deux choses que vous avez vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure déjà concernant la
sécurité vous reconnaissez effectivement
ce que tout le monde s'accorde à dire
c'est qu'il y aura sûrement un problème
de recrutement pour les forces privées
failles de sécurité donc et vous nous
disiez
ce sera les forces de l'ordre police
gendarmerie qui devront donc suppléer
cette
défaillance et c'est le kojote qui
paiera mais le problème c'est pas
tellement payé même si évidemment
l'aspect financier est extrêmement
important mais c'est un problème de
ressources humaines parce que policier
et gendarmes qui sont 120000 chacun sont
comme l'ont dit pardon pour l'expression
mais Allos il y a des
manifestations sportives d'autres
manifestations sportives qui seront
décalées les manifestations musicales
festival etc etc donc le kojote paira
mais père acquis puisqu'il y aura plus
de force de l'ordre permettant de
supplier cette défaillance de la
sécurité et puis concernant la
billetterie mon collègue au double
donnait quelques exemples de prix vous
nous dites c'est par la billetterie que
l'on pourra peut-être limiter ce déficit
mais on va aller jusqu'où comme ça merci
merci monsieur le député monsieur le
Premier Président vous avez la parole
pour répondre j'ai commencé par la
question sur la force de nos
recommandations
dans une autre vie j'ai été des vôtres
j'étais un homme politique on n'oublie
jamais complètement c'est comme la
bicyclette
on aurait parfois mais bon je suis dans
un autre vie maintenant je respecte la
politique et je respecte les politiques
donc je sais ce que la Cour des comptes
n'est pas la Cour des comptes n'est pas
un après 10 de l'exécutif nous n'avons
pas décidé à la place de l'exécutif nous
ne sommes pas non plus un appendice nous
sommes à équidistance entre le
gouvernement elle Parlement nous sommes
là pour éclairer le débat public par nos
analyses
ça nous donne
non pas un pouvoir non pas un
contre-pouvoir je n'y prétends pas je ne
crois pas la République des juges je ne
crois pas la pluie des technocrates ou
des experts ça nous donne un rôle
d'influence qui est certain nous sommes
toujours lus nous sommes respectés par
les Français
qui a 70% de taux d'approbation
tout le monde peut être dire autant
nous sommes entendus souvent mais c'est
le politique ensuite qui se saisit c'est
réfutable ce que nous disons ce sont des
constats objectifs dans une période
quand même de fake news et des
informations c'est pas inutile ensuite
nous suivons nos recommandations en
général 78% de recommandations sont
suivies c'est pas mal je constate aussi
qu'un certain nombre de gros
orientations ne sont pas
reprises je ne m'en plains pas parce que
il y a une liberté dans ce pays du
gouvernement et du Parlement et
manquerait plus que on suive que je
n'aimerais pas un pays qui soit dirigé
par la Cour des comptes ni par le
Conseil d'État ni pas rien ça c'est un
équipe démocratique nous sommes une
institution de la République
s'agissant de ce sujet particulier je
pense que nos recommandations sont plus
suivies pourquoi parce que c'est un
modèle original c'est-à-dire que nous
sommes embarqués en quelque sorte nous
travaillons en continu avec les pouvoirs
publics et forcément nous sommes
informés en temps réel et ils tiennent
compte en temps réel de nos
recommandations je peux dire oui sous le
contrôle de l'équipe que vraiment là
nous sommes une partie prenante du
processus de la décision même si encore
une fois c'est pas nous qui la prenons
nous contribuons fortement à celle-ci et
ça vaut en particulier monsieur le petit
peu sur le Stade de France
j'ai dit je crois que vous étiez sorti
assez précisément ce que nous faisons
donc je ne veux pas le répéter
je veux commencer par une question qui
est fondamentale que plusieurs d'entre
vous ont
poser qui essaie de l'héritage en
particulier en Seine-Saint-Denis et sur
les territoires
pas les investissements réalisés à
l'occasion de leur préparation qu'ils
soient directement liés à l'organisme
des jeux ou qu'il soit permis par
l'événement les jeux sont l'occasion
d'accélérer le développement du
territoire qui accueillent les
compétitions
en province c'est Marseille où Lille par
exemple comment région parisienne en
particulier sur le député Corbières en
Seine-Saint-Denis ou un effet rattrapage
est attendu des jeux avec une ambition
affichée en tout cas de réduire les
inégalités sociales et territoriales
bénéficiera pas des jeux tout de même
parce que là il y a quelques chiffres
qui sont assez précis 1,1 milliard
d'euros d'argent public sur les trois au
final
et je ne parle que sur les deux cas que
nous connaissons il est investi à
l'occasion des Jeux à travers diverses
opérations de renouvellement urbain
80% du financement public de ce vidéo
est dirigé vers le département selon une
déléguée internicielle aux Jeux
Olympiques
deux tiers des opérations portées par
l'établissement public sont situés en
Seine-Saint-Denis dans les plus grosses
opérations le village des athlètes le
village des médias le centre aquatiques
les ponts et passerelles la construction
du village des athlètes c'est une
cinquantaine d'hectares à cheval sur
Saint-Denis Saint-Ouen et sur l'île
Saint-Denis qui sera reconvertie après
les jeux en 2800 logements pérenne dont
un quart de logements sociaux et en
commerce 100 000 m² de bureau et de
services au sein de bâtiments qui
devront être construits selon les normes
environnementales les plus récentes et
on attend 6000 habitants et 6000
salariés il y a aussi le construction du
village des médias d'unis au Bourget qui
devrait accueillir près de 1300
logements après les Jeux
il y a construction de sites et de lieu
d'entraînement la rénovation
d'équipements sportifs la construction
du hall 3 du Parc des Expositions du
Bourget la réinstallation après les jeux
à Pierrefitte-sur-Seine et Sevran 3
bassins de baignade utilisé à Paris il a
défense Arena
il y a la réalité
pour y installer un hôtel 4 étoiles et
des bureaux au niveau du carrefour
Pleyel enfin il y a les aménagements de
l'espace public réduction des coupures
urbaines aménagement des ports de Seine
pour les pelouses piétons enfouissement
des lignes haute tension au nord du
village olympique mur antibruit au sud
de la 86 franchissement urbain Pleyel
tout ça pour dire que
franchement je pense que il se passera
des choses dans cette année ça ne répond
pas à la totalité la question et c'est
pas totalement ce que vous voulez dire
je le sais Niel totalité des questions
des députés et là-dessus j'y reviens sur
l'héritage en général je l'ai dit et je
le redis
nous n'avons pas plus que vous
d'indicateurs nous souhaitons qu'il nous
soit fournis les 160 mesures sont une
déclaration d'attention que nous prenons
en compte tous mais derrière ça il faut
passer des déclarations d'attention aux
actes il faut hiérarchiser les 170
mesures
la Cour ne s'y est pas intéressée parce
que papa intéressé
nous manquons cette stratégie
nous y reviendrons et tout le monde doit
être vigilant là-dessus mais enfin tout
de même ils sont la scène Saint-Denis
disons le je pense que
ce département peut espérer des
transformations qui viennent des jeux
tout de même des questions ont été
posées sur la reconversion des
équipements ce qui est démontable c'est
aussi particulier
au niveau départemental là aussi nous
regarderons cela de plus près pour ce
qui est de la commande publique et du
respect de marché à ce stade nous avons
procédé je dis bien petit contrôle sur
une échantillon limité de marché
mais tout le travail reste à faire quand
tous les marchés seront passés exécutés
nous avons juste eu rappelé les règles
de la commande publique de manière
générale sur une commande publique et
sur l'axelle et TPE PME la cour et
l'échangeurs des comptes conduiront un
travail exhaustif expost et nous
veillerons notamment c'est une question
qui a été posée par plusieurs députés
est-ce que le pourcentage de 25%
soit respecté pour ce qui est du recours
à la vidéo surveillance question qui a
été posée
je n'ai pas en tête exactement par de
moi je peux pas vous dire
ce que disait tout à fait le rapport sur
la police municipale je sais ce que dit
celui-ci
j'imagine qu'il y a à la fois des
changements de contact et puis il peut y
avoir aussi des appréciations
différentes selon les équipes ça arrive
le Cours des comptes il y a aussi une
certaine forme de pluralisme mais en
tout cas c'est un sujet qui sera débattu
dans le cadre de la loi olympique qui
passe nos informations mardi au Sénat
dans la foulée nationale et c'est vous
qui serait amené à prendre les décisions
l'État et à poser à ceux qui prennent
les décisions les questions
ils sont toutefois l'équipe qui conduit
ce rapport et je la prouve que
obscures des réflexions même si après
toute une série garantie doivent être
prises et je peux comprendre les
préoccupations qui s'expriment à cet
égard sur le prix des billets
c'est vrai qui est pas de billets PAS
CHER ça relève des décisions du kojob le
rôle de la Cour n'est pas de se
prononcer sur le prix des billets il est
prononcé en revanche sur l'équilibre
financier de l'opération et notons que
toute baisse de la billetterie alors je
parle pas du prix des billets mais du
rendement global de la billetterie
entraînera des coûts en direct qu'il
faudra bien compenser ce qui veut dire
que ce qui ne sera pas payé par ceux qui
enjeux sera payé par le contribuable en
pratique
j'aurais quand même faire une remarque
qui sort de mon rôle mais qui essaie
d'un citoyen c'est que il nous arrive
à nous différents
classes sociales d'avoir des loisirs
pour autant qu'on le peut
c'est pas exactement la même chose que
le système de olympiques que des cinémas
parce que des films qui sortent il y en
a toutes les semaines les Olympiques
c'est tous les 100 ans et donc il est
pas totalement absurde que le prix d'un
tel événement compte une sorte Arte soit
un peu plus élevée après
il n'empêche que c'est une question qui
peut être posée je trouve légitime mais
il y a des gens qui ont au jeu y compris
avec des moyens modestes parce que c'est
quelque chose qu'on fait une fois dans
sa vie
je pense que ça joue mais en tout cas
nous suivrons ça de près enfin vous êtes
revenu les uns et les autres ou
plusieurs d'entre vous sur la question
sécuritaire
le
ministère intérieur
travail sur des scénarios de monter en
charge des forces intérieures
surtout en cas de carence la sécurité
privée je redis que pour nous cette
carence est
probable compte tenu de l'état de ce
marché monsieur le député c'est pas
qu'en France que cette question se pose
c'est une question en réalité largement
européenne il y a des précédents un
pensant au jeu de Londres
l'éventualité d'un recours à la police à
la gendarmerie ou Forza mais comme dans
ces jeux n'est pas exclure dans tous les
cas s'il est à fait à la place du cojote
il appartient à ce dernier de compenser
financièrement ça je pense que c'est de
bonne gestion mais encore une fois je
dis il y a plusieurs fois
plusieurs reprises ici notre message qui
était un message parfois d'alerte mais
pas d'alarme
je partage pas tout à fait votre
sentiment mais c'est à l'État aussi de
le démontrer
nos forces de sécurité intérieures ont
les moyens de faire face à ce défi
capacitaire elles en ont les moyens en
Île-de-France et le devoir elles ont
dans le moyen sur les sites des jeux
elles ont dans le moyen surtout le
territoire ce sera sans doute un moment
très tendu et un vrai défi pour nos
forces de sécurité nous pouvons
toutefois leur faire confiance mais
encore une fois c'est un des messages
que j'ai essayé de passer tout au long
de cette entretien de cet échange que
j'ai eu avec vous avec grand plaisir
avec mon équipe le temps le temps et le
facteur clé ne perdons pas de temps pour
prendre les décisions en matière de
sécurité les défis sont là les moyens
d'y répondre existent ne perdons pas de
temps
merci madame le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
[Musique]
dans l'instruction que nous avons faite
nous avons fait un certain nombre de
recommandations qu'au job d'abord parce
que nous considérions que la direction
des ressources humaines était
sous-dimensionnée d'ailleurs depuis ce
qui illustre le propos du président
Mosco ici les effectifs de cette
direction était
remontée et effectivement on a pointé ça
fait partie de ce rôle d'alerte ils ont
3500 personnes à recruter en 2023 2024
alors il y a le discours réconciste à
dire tout le monde veut venir travailler
pour les jeux et nous on répond que ça
se fait un certain nombre de conditions
qui étaient notamment le renforcement de
la direction des ressources humaines il
faut aussi appel à Randstad et on a
alerté sur le fait que le contexte avait
changé notamment il y a des tensions sur
le marché du travail et donc c'était un
défi à relever comme il y a un défi à la
Solido de savoir garder jusqu'au bout
ces cadres donc
ça se passe bien il y a pas de raison
que ça ne se passe pas mais l'alerte de
la cour c'était de dire c'est pas
naturel ça va pas forcément se faire
spontanément donc il faut être
extrêmement attentif temps du point de
vue du kojob et de la solideo que du
point de vue des services de l'État
voilà l'alerte qu'on a fait mais on n'a
pas d'éléments qui laissent à penser
qu'ils ne seront pas recruter simplement
c'est peut-être plus compliqué que prévu
il faut pas partir de l'idée que parce
que c'est les jeux tout le monde a envie
de venir travailler dans n'importe quel
condition et la réussite des jeux c'est
ces 3500 personnes mais c'est aussi les
45 000 volontaires ou là encore le
discours général consiste à dire mais
tout le monde veut être volontaire pour
les jeux la vérité c'est qu'il faut les
recruter tôt il faut les cibler il faut
les former et c'est pas complètement
évident donc on peut pas dire que les
46000 volontaires ils arrivent là sans
qu'on soit attentif à la manière dont on
le préparait c'était notre devoir
d'alerte de signaler ces problèmes ne
serait-ce que pour dans ce rôle
d'influence
les choses soient vraiment pris en
compte par ceux qui ont la
responsabilité de de les exécuter
merci beaucoup donc mes chers collègues
donc merci de votre participation merci
monsieur le Premier Président Madame et
messieurs pour votre vos réponses et les
exposer que vous avez pu faire je
rappelle que nous allons visiter le
village des athlètes le vent le mercredi
8 février donc nous irons voir en vrai
alors certains encore mais non c'est pas
exactement la même visite puisque nous
avons en effet une instance qui a déjà
été visitée qui est le groupe de travail
sur les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
mais qui n'englobe pas toute la
commission donc toute la Commission est
invitée à visiter le village des
athlètes le 8 février et autrement à la
Commission se retrouve mardi prochain à
17h45 pour l'audition de Bénédicte
Lesage pressenti par la présidente Bron
pivée ou pour sier au sein du collège de
l'arcom audition qui sera suivie du vote
sur cette désignation donc mes chers
collègues je vous souhaite une bonne fin
d'après-midi et au plaisir de vous
retrouver la semaine prochaine